please subscribe please subscribe
for clewid south
and i did the appeal but i didn't think
they could get jeffrey archer
that day because we as as you will
recall we'd be more or less wiped out
and what a joy it is to come back here
today quarter of a century on and find
that we have more conservative mps than
at any time since the 1980s and that we
not only hold clever south we hold
blackpool south my friend
and
thank you as we as we as we meet today a
tragedy
continues to unfold in our european
continent a vicious and a barbarian
attack
on innocent civilians the like of which
we haven't seen
since the 1940s and
mr ambassador so i know there you are
thank you mr ambassador ukrainian
ambassador i want to repeat to you
directly what i told your wonderful
president vladimir yesterday we stand
with the ukrainian people
and our hearts
go out to them
and tens of thousands of people in this
country are opening our homes to the
people of ukraine we say thank you to
them and we applaud them and
with every day that ukraine's heroic
resistance continues it is clear that
putin has made a catastrophic mistake
and you have to ask yourself why he did
it why did he decide to invade this
totally innocent country
he didn't really believe that ukraine
was going to join nato any so anytime
soon he knew perfectly well there was no
plan to put missiles on ukrainian soil
he didn't really believe the
semi-mystical guff he wrote about the
origins of the of the russian people and
you read it nostradamus meets russian
wikipedia i think that wasn't what it
was about
i think i i think he was frightened of
ukraine for an entirely different reason
he was frightened of ukraine because in
ukraine
they have a free press and in ukraine
they have free elections and with every
year that ukraine progressed not always
easily towards freedom and democracy and
open markets he
feared the ukrainian example and he
feared the implicit reproach to himself
because in putin's russia you get jailed
for 15 years just for calling an
invasion an invasion and if you stand
against putin in an election you get
poisoned or shot and
it's it's precisely that's what happens
and it's precisely because you ukraine
and russia have been so historically
close uh that he has been terrified of
the effect of that ukrainian model on
him and on russia and he's been in a
total panic about a so-called color
revolution in moscow itself and that's
why he's trying so brutally to snuff out
the flame of freedom in ukraine and
that's why it is so vital that he fails
because a victorious
a victorious putin
a victorious putin will not stop in
ukraine and the end of freedom in
ukraine will mean the extinction of any
hope of freedom in georgia and then
moldova it will mean the beginning of a
new age of intimidation across the whole
of eastern europe from the baltic to the
black sea and if putin succeeds in
crushing ukraine it will be the green
light for autocrats everywhere in the
middle east in the far east
this
is a turning point
for the world and it's a moment of
choice it's a choice
between freedom and oppression
and i know there are some around the
world even in some western governments
who invoke what they call real politique
and who say that we're better off making
accommodations
with tyranny
i have to say i believe they are
profoundly wrong
and that to try to re-normalize
relations with putin
after this
as we did in 2014
would be to make exactly the same
mistake again and
and that is why
and that is why putin must fail and i
know
that it's the instinct of the people of
this country
like the people of ukraine
to choose freedom
every time
i can give you a couple of famous recent
examples
when the british people voted for brexit
in such large numbers i don't believe it
was because they were remotely hostile
to to foreigners
it's because they wanted to be free
to do things differently and for this
country to be able to run itself
give you another example where the
british population came forward to be
vaccinated
at such incredible speed voluntarily
unlike many other countries
i'm sure it was of course partly because
they wanted to avoid catching cobit
very sensible thing to do by the way i
hope you've all had your boosters
and
here you have
well we're getting ready for a fall for
a fourth jab because we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna need it
but i tell you why people did it why did
the british people come forward i mean
90 we got entirely voluntary
entirely voluntarily it was because they
wanted
to get on with their life they were fed
up
with being told what to do
by people like me
they were
we wanted to take back control of our
lives and uh so i'm proud that this
government has done the things that so
many people said were impossible we got
brexit done i'm proud that we deliver
the fastest vaccine rollout in europe
not once but twice and the the fastest
booster rollout and uh of course yes i
am proud that this government has been
in the lead in sticking up for freedom
in ukraine
this was the first european country to
send defensive weapons to help the
ukrainians and now dozens are following
our lead and i'm very grateful to my
friend ben wallace also there in the
front row for his foresight many months
ago
and for getting me to read putin's crazy
essay uh which i did
and uh we're talking continuously liz uh
ben and i were talking continuously uh
to our colleagues uh in the uh in the uh
the ukraine support group to discuss
what more we can do and those those
conversations go on literally every day
and there will be more i'm proud of uh
what we did on sanctions we were we're
in the lead in sanctioning swift and the
and the banks when banning aeroflot
we've now sanctioned more banks and
individuals than any other european
country and we will be distributing
their yachts and their and their assets
and
and of course there is a cost
to all these actions of course there is
but the cost of doing nothing
would be far far higher
putin's
putin's war is intended to cause
economic damage to the west and to
benefit him and he knows that with every
dollar increase in the price of a barrel
of oil he gets billions more in revenues
from the sales of oil and oil and gas
and that's the
the tragedy of the situation he's been
preparing for this moment
uh by pushing hydrocarbons on the west
like a backstreet pusher feeding our
addiction creating a dependency
and now he wants to weaken the
collective will to resist by pushing up
the cost of living hitting us
at the pumps and in our fuel bills
and so we must respond we've got to do
everything we can to help people with
their daily costs help people with the
cost of living and of course that means
doing all the things that we're doing
lifting the living wage cutting council
tax bills helping with uh fuel costs
giving billions to councils uh millions
more to help people in a particular
hardship the best possible
our answer of course is to make sure
that this is the traditional
conservative answer to make sure that we
have a strong economy and strong
economic fundamentals with well-paid
jobs and thanks to the speed of that
booster rollout we have the fastest
growing economy in the g7 unemployment
now actually back to
the level it was before the pandemic
virtually a record low uh 3.9 youth
unemployment at or near uh record lows
but
if we're going to deal with the
particular cost the the biggest cost
that families now face and tackle these
rising fuel bills the energy spike
we must take the bold steps necessary to
end our
dependence on putin's oil and gas
and that is what
that is what we are doing in the
immortal phrase it is time to take back
control of our energy supplies
after
after years of short-termism and
hand-to-mouth solutions we are setting
out a british energy security strategy
and we will make better use of our own
naturally occurring hydrocarbons
rather than import them top dollar from
abroad and put the money into putin's
bank account
that does not mean
in any way that we will abandon our
drive for a low carbon future we're
going to make some bets on nuclear power
some big bets on nuclear power not just
the big projects but also the small
modular reactors and we're going to take
that bullet to gate spirit
of the booster rollout and use it to
build more offshore wind at double quick
time
and many other
investments in clean green power but if
you ask me how we're going to pay for
all this i can tell you that i've been
going around the world recently and i've
been talking to international investors
who are yearning to make colossal
long-term investments in british green
infrastructure colossal and there's a
reason why people want to come to this
country many many reasons uh
why they want to come
but you're seeing them invest massively
in uh everything from tech to finance to
to green park and
that is that they know what this
government is doing they know about i
mean you may not believe it but they do
they know about our leveling up agenda
my friends
they do
they've heard of it they have
they're very well informed and
they know that we have a plan to unleash
the potential of this whole country and
they can see how we are doing it making
our streets safer 20 000 more police
rounding up the county lines drugs gangs
that cause such misery
stopping and searching the kids with the
with the knives giving the police the
powers that they need and by the way uh
giving the the criminals the serious
sentences that they deserve uh for the
crimes that they commit
the middle class drugs use by the way
that helps to drive uh so much of the
consumption but doing things thank you
for that small clap for that uh
i i i think it's about i think it's
about time that the government stood
that the government said that we don't
tolerate uh this kind of conservative it
is driving uh misery across the whole
country it's driving uh the county lines
gangs and we should be absolutely frank
about it but what we're doing goes far
beyond that and people around the world
can see what leveling up is doing the
the massive extension of fiber optic
broadband and i i'm just trying to look
for nadine where where house is absolute
dean isn't in here but we are oliver you
were you you were doing it massive it's
massive expansion uh massive expansion
when you were at dcms of full fiber of
gigabit broadband uh it is it is a great
thing for our country uh and we need to
do it we will go further and faster
investing massively in
in road and rail and not just the
colossal uh schemes of the integrated
rail plan northern powerhouse rail
making sure that the uh the midlands and
the and the north of the country finally
get the kind of commuter style rail
networks that have been taken for
granted for so long uh in the southeast
uh huge schemes that we're doing they'll
be transformative for the uk economy but
look at the little things that we're
doing as well uh
or relatively smaller schemes such as
the the new tram improvements in
blackpool uh which i was
delighted to see the other day
i congratulate i congratulate the
blackpool authorities on on what they
are doing because uh it's driving
tourism it's driving investment even
more investment here in in blackboard
that's what leveling up is i went for a
run so you may not believe it but i did
i went for a run this morning on the
beach absolutely beautiful
better than anything in the caribbean
i probably that is not near gallantry it
is it is true
and it's true i mean that time of the
morning uh 6 45 uh sun coming up
unbelievable he was tied right out
ribbed sand stretching from for miles
miles and absolutely beautiful and as i
ran along i saw all the new hotels and
the uh the
new attractions that will benefit from
that new transport infrastructure going
in the new the new tram of course
government has a role
safer streets better health care better
schools better education creating the
conditions for that investment
but in the end you need the private
sector
the animal spirits of the private sector
to come in and have the confidence to
invest
that's what it's all about that's the
fundamental symmetry at the heart of our
conservative vision and as i was running
along the sand i saw a man
who seemed to be prospecting with a kind
of steel pole
or tube and i asked him what he was
looking for hydrocarbons or perhaps
and
what do you think he was looking for
does anybody have any idea
i'll tell you he was not always in oil
well he was he was looking for lug worms
and he showed me some lug worms that he
had caught and i will tell you my
friends the lug worm is not perhaps the
most beautiful of god's creatures
but bigger fish love lug worms and i
want you to know that we conservatives
back everybody in this country who gets
up early and invest their time and their
skill and their energy and their effort
in the hope of a bigger return and that
is
you need
you need to use a lug worm you need to
use a lug worm to catch a bream my
friends and i have a bream as they say i
have a breed
i have i have a breed of
a vision of a one nation conservatism
that a one nation conservatism that
takes that capitalist spirit and use it
uses our wonderful free market system to
make sure that we have the revenues
further for richie soon act to pay for
our fantastic nhs and the 50 000 more
nurses and the thousands more doctors uh
that we're hiring pay for all the
wonderful staff
who are clearing the covered backlogs
pay for our defenses pay for pay for ben
wallace's uh troops pay for our 20 000
more police officers pay for investment
in skills
like what we're doing uh with the black
blackpool and filed college the new
multiversity that's opening because that
is what uh leveling up is all about and
it's it that it is those wonderful
public services that create the climate
of confidence which means that private
sector investment comes in and it works
this this formula leveling up i believe
is right for the whole country it's
vital to understand this it's vital it
works it works everywhere by unleashing
talent everywhere across the uk still
under the old model the uh the the most
imbalanced uh european economy by
unleashing talent everywhere you stop
the overheating and the stress and the
over development that is a part of the
failed economic model and we take the
whole country forward together that's
what we're going to do that's why rishi
i think is totally right to be driving a
new age of post-brexit entrepreneurial
entrepreneurialism
word to say you know what
no but you know what i mean uh no
low business taxes and other fiscal
incentives the the the eight new uh free
ports and all the new freedoms that
we're currently taking uh driven by
jacob uh who's uh our invigilator of
these things to do things differently
and do things better uh now that we can
and i think it's because of the spirit
that people can see in this country that
we're seeing a surge of investment in
the last few months another billion just
to this week from alphana
from saudi arabia in t-side to make
green aviation fuel top of a billion
from nissan for a giga a gigafactory of
billion from mubardala
for life sciences 6 billion for ibadrola
a spanish company in east anglian wind
farms 1.5 billion from blackstone from
labs and the creative sector the list
goes on and on it is absolutely
astonishing a billion here a billion
there you're talking about serious money
you're talking about tens of thousands
of high-wage high-skilled jobs and
there's another reason of course why
investors come here and when they think
about the uk
and uh what it's gonna be like for
themselves and their their families they
think about the time that they're going
to be spending in
the uk
and
i'll tell you something it is the
invincible strength of of this country
that we believe
by and large
and within the law
that people
should be able to do whatever they want
provided they don't do any harm to
anybody else
[Applause]
and that's called freedom
that's called freedom
and we don't need to be woke
we just want to be free
and that's why talented people are
fleeing russia quite frankly right now
and that's why they're flocking to the
uk and to get back to my theme it's
that's that's putin's tragedy
that's his tragedy there actually
there's a sense in which
his disastrous
error
in ukraine is itself an argument for
democracy
and freedom
i mean seriously if putin had a free
press
if he had the bbc on his case
well let's
be serious
he would know
whatever you may think
he would have known the truth
that or a version of it he would have
known the truth
no no come on
if he had if he had free
if he had free impartial responsible
journalists let me put it that way
then he would have known then he would
have known the truth
that the ukrainians
are a proud proud nation
with a charismatic leader and he would
have known before he set out on this
disastrous and inhuman venture that they
would fight to defend their homeland he
would have known that and he wouldn't
have locked himself in this echo chamber
of sycophants
by on which subject if putin had to
explain himself to a real parliament
with real backbenchers
whom of course
all leaders must have a very very lively
regard
who had to who had to here here
who
backbenchers who had to justify
themselves every day
to their electors not to not and of
course at elections
you know i don't believe that
he would have been capable of such a
crescendo of disastrous and
self-destructive mistakes
isn't that the truth
now that i i don't i've got to i don't
believe that democratic freedoms are
going to sprout anytime soon in the
kremlin
far from it but with every day that
passes i think that putin becomes a more
glaring advertisement for the system
that he hates and despises and it
becomes ever more obvious why we have to
stick up for ukraine and we will and
that's why we will continue
with absolute conviction
to stick up for freedom under the law
freedom under the law at home and abroad
even if it means making some tough
decisions
we made a tough choice for instance over
over christmas and new year to keep
going to keep our economy open when some
people said we should go back into into
lockdown we made the tough choice to
open up last july
when i think that the labour party said
we were being reckless
never forget if we'd listen to captain
hindsight and the labour party i never
tire of telling you this but it's true
we would still be in lockdown and we
would certainly not be seeing the strong
growth and employment that we're seeing
today
when
when the labour party and the current
leader were trying with might and main
to install a leader who wanted i'm sorry
i'm but i'm serious to abolish nato
we were already training ukrainian
troops to fight
and it's an absolutely incredible fact
but it's true at a time when russia is
being led by a president who is capable
of bullying and threats and who's
plainly capable of making dangerous and
irrational decisions we have a labor
party whose shadow cabinet is stuffed
with people who only recently voted
to abolish the uk's independent nuclear
deterrent that's right eight of them the
shadow foreign secretary unbelievable
the shadow leveling up secretary shadow
transport section i haven't got the
entire list but you can find it out
that's them
do we want them in charge my friends at
this moment do we want them running up
the white flag
do you see them standing up to putin's
blackmail i i don't by the way in the
next few weeks do we want them running
our councils when we know that up and
down the country labor councils cost you
more and conservatives deliver better
services do we want them in charge of
the economy of this amazing country of
ours when there has never been a labor
government that left with unemployment
lower than when they arrived
let me tell you when you go out
campaigning in the in the next few weeks
as we all will uh joyfully let me tell
you uh that it the my message to of to
everybody on the doorstep is that it is
conservatives
it's conservatives who get things done
even when they look difficult and it's
conservatives who take the tough
decisions to help you to be on your side
to help you with the cost of living
and it's conservatives who stand up for
freedom against the blackmail of
vladimir putin and
i'll tell you why we do
it and we do it
we do it not out of ideology because we
know through long experience that it's
only by sticking up for freedom that we
can deliver long-term prosperity and
security and that's what we will deliver
together thank you all very much and
thank you for coming to spring
conference thank you
thank you
you